the org and now I'm book TV we want to
introduce you to Connie lon
ms lon what's your career been it has
been amazing that's why I detailed it in
my book I'm senior White House
correspondent
I started in 1968 which was an amazing
year I had one of the last interviews
with Bobby Kennedy before he was shot
I got accolades from Nelson Mandela who
said he used to listen to me in jail and
when he met me he picked me up he swung
me around he said you're not as big as I
thought you were I got beaten up in
Chicago in 1968 during the Democratic
convention went to Czechoslovakia after
the Russians moved in spend six months
there made about 18 trips to Israel
spent a lot of time covering the Middle
East and still covering presidents for
what station where can people find your
work right now I do srn on the weekend
sale and radio news and contribute blogs
to huffingtonpost.com but you know I
hope most people will leave my book you
wake me each morning the final edition
and it's the final edition because I've
got Parkinson's disease you know we're
all terminal at some point in our life
and I guess I'm more terminal than
others I'm under hospice care the
hospitals people are great and they come
to my house one of their mottos is
hospitals for people have had more
yesterday's than tomorrow's Conny lon
how long have you had Parkinson's what's
that done for your work oh it's horrible
I've had it for about five years it's
very painful
I've lost my voice I have a lot of
trouble rod casting thank god I can
still type and compute on her computer
but it takes me an hour to do one
paragraph I can't write you lose your
lose your handwriting completely
mobility is affected it affects every
part of the body it's very cruel disease
I feel terrible about Roger me well as
we're standing here now at the National
Press Club how do you feel very weak
very shaky but energized talking to you
one point did I think I'm making my book
is that I don't have much me I lived
through other people that's why I go to
the White House as much as I can I'm
sincerely interested in people and so
you know I've got to be with my friends
you can see I'm shunned trembling now as
we talk where did the title come from
you wake me every morning you wake each
morning the final edition that was an
ambassador Sam Lewis from Israel as I
was at a press conference and we were
supposed to identify ourselves as I said
Connie lon Connie law no you wake me
each morning so that was nice but lots
of thousands of people have told me the
same thing kind of nice well let's let's
very quickly look at your career and
just give us a snapshot of presidents
that were fun to cover and difficult to
cover well Barack Obama is a good
president I like him but he's difficult
to cover kind of boring in the old days
with the other presidents in a half hour
news conference you'd have maybe 20
reporters asking one question each now
you're lucky if you have four reporters
chosen by the President or riot staff
and once they get the floor they can go
on and on and on and they're not
listening to what the president says
they're repeating the same questions I
always try to ask different questions
but they've been fun presidents revered
Clinton was the best most exciting to
cover Reagan was fascinating
so staying in my mind is the best to
presidents to cover how'd you get into
this business well I started out working
on Capitol Hill I was a political
science major Capitol Hill was deadly
boring and I went up to New Hampshire
with Eugene McCarthy in 1968 was
canvassing for him and then I saw the
reporters were having much more fun so I
morphed into a reporter those were
really hard days we slept on church pews
I slept anyplace I could in closets
whatever I had no finances that's what
makes my book different the fact that I
did it all myself I'd never worked for a
big company but I worked for a series of
companies and that's the way to survive
in this business now I'd have 10 or 14
different clients or different countries
maybe they'd pay me at the most 10,000 a
year but you can make a living that way
I never had anybody pay me very big
bucks I never had insurance so I did
that myself investments myself this is
the age of the entrepreneur everybody's
a journalist now I predicted that what
happened in 1968 and I think it's
wonderful citizen journalism it's
fantastic the name of the book you wake
me each morning the final chapter the
author senior White House correspondent
Connie lon thanks for your time and it's
online than a baton